اتضح المشهد السياسي في تركيا قبل
انتخابات الاعاده الاحد القادم الاصطفافات
اكتملت مع انقسام تحالف الاجداد بين
المرشحين الرئيسيين في الانتخابات الرئيس
رجب طيب اردوغان وزعيم المعارضه كمال
كلجدارلو زعيم المعارضه الذي خسر في
البرلمان تلقى دفعه معنويه باعلان حزب
النصر المعادي للاجئين دعمه له
ادعموا سياسيين الذين سيرسلون ثلاثه عشر
مليون لاجئ الى وطنهم في الانتخابات
المقرره اجراؤها في 28 من مايو وصوتوا
لصالح كمال كلجدار اوغلو بيان اوزداغ وكل
جدار اوغلو جاء بعد يومين من اعلان المرشح
الخاسر سنان اوغان وهو من كوادر حزب النصر
تاييده لاردوغان في الجوله الثانيه اعلان
قال حزب النصر انه لا يمثل الا وجهه نظر
اوغان وسائل اعلام مقربه من المعارضه قالت
ان كلش دارولو وعد اوميت اوزداغ بتولي
وزاره الداخليه في حال فازه المعارضه
بالانتخابات على الطرف الاخر قالت وسائل
اعلام ان اوغان طلب من اردوغان ان يتسلم
وزاره الكوارث في حال تم تاسيس مثل هكذا
وزاره الى اليوم في قدم الايام قد يتحصل
اوغان على منصب حتى وان لم يكن هذا هدفه
الا ان الرئيس اردوغان سيقدره على صعيد
اخر الاتفاق بين كيلج دار اوغلو واوزدار
جاء وفق صفقه تبادل مصالح تحالف الامه
بصوره عامه مبني على تقاسم المصالح لذلك
لن ينجح في جوله الاعاده
وتركزت الدعايه الانتخابيه
ومعسكره قبل جوله الاعاده على ترحيل
اللاجئين من تركيا في محاوله اخيره لجذب
القوميين المتشددين الذين صوت لسينانوغان
في الجوله الاولى
بعد دعم حزب النصر لكريجدار اوغلو تتجه
الانظار نحو الكتله الكرديه
حزب
الشعوب وهي التي دعمت زعيم المعارضه في
الجوله الاولى فازداغ يعادي الحزمه الكردي
بقدر ما يعادي وجود اللاجئين في تركيا
وهنا السؤال يعود مجددا هل ستنحاز هذه
الكتله مره ثانيه لك بعد تحالفه مع اوزلاغ
زيدان زنجلو العربيه اسطنبول
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات